bonsoir fabien et merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france le projet loi
climat et résidences près de sept mille
amendements on l'a dit on été déposé on
sent bien que le texte ne fait pas
l'unanimité mais que des critiques
reviennent souvent notamment une est ce
vraiment un texte au rabais ce avant
vous vous le dire il n'ya pas que les
oppositions qu'il le dise il ya aussi
des ong
très mobilisés sur la question
climatique qui ont défilé hier dans les
rues massivement puisque plus de cent
dix mille personnes étaient réunies à
paris est beaucoup plus à travers la
france et j'étais moi-même avec d'autres
mes camarades présents à cette
manifestation mme il ya aussi le haut
conseil pour le climat qui fustige le
peu de portée et le flou qui entoure
notamment sur les questions de
calendrier ce projet de loi et puis ce
sont les 150 citoyens eux-mêmes qui aura
été un peu fou et qui se sent trahi
puisque on leur avait dit voilà
faites-nous 150 propositions et nous les
donnerons sans filtre soit directement
parlement soit directement par
référendum au peuple français et les
citoyens eux mêmes ces 150 citoyens ont
attribué la note de deux et demi sur dix
au projet de loi climat et résilience
dont il ya un mécontentement général qui
se comprend parce que ce texte n'aura
aucune portée pour sauver notre climat
et ne répondent pas aux grands enjeux
qui sont posés devant nous celui de
sauver le climat la planète et
l'ensemble des vivants et notamment les
humains ouverte unième siècle
selon yannick jadot on est à un tiers de
l'objectif je ne sais pas si vous
partagez ce diagnostic
la faute à quoi à qui c'est l'ambition
qui manque c'est un mauvais diagnostic
de la situation de mauvaises solutions
vous vous l'expliquez comment nonce
c'est la volonté politique
emmanuel macron ne souhaite pas changer
le système et nous savons maintenant que
si nous voulons sauver le climat il nous
faut une révolution de nos modes de
production de nos modes de consommation
de nos modes de transport dans la
question du lot
je monte dans les questions d'énergie et
donc ça ça demande une volonté politique
de rompre avec le système capitaliste
mais manuel mata qu'on ne peut pas lui
donner ça c'est le meilleur garant du
système qui est aujourd'hui en place et
puis je rappelle quand même qu emmanuel
macron c'est celui qui est comme
président car et autoriser les
néonicotinoïdes c'est celui qui continue
à signer à tour de bras des traités de
libre échange et notamment la question
du sénat où d'hubert qu'aux qui est
toujours à l'ordre du jour c'est celui
qui ne protège pas 50% de biodiversité
qui se trouve en guyane et qui est
menacé aujourd'hui par la déforestation
et par leur taille âge légal de
l'industriel est illégale et aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron continue à signer des
autorisations pour que des mines
industrielles se fasse donc vous voyez
en fait en réalité ce n'est pas un
mauvais diagnostic
tout le monde sait que nous courons à la
catastrophe la france se réchauffent
encore plus vite que le reste du monde
chaque année nous épuisons encore plus
rapidement le ressources que l'année
précédente
donc il faut rompre avec ce système
capitaliste et ça ça demande une
révolution sa demande de sortir des lois
du marché sa demande que le profit passe
après l'humain la planète lui
aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron ne le souhaite pas parce
qu'ils ne partagent pas cette ambition
politique
là où le bât blesse fabien gay c'est
aussi la méthode non alors que les
propositions issues de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ont été peu
suivi un processus démocratique inédit
bafoués dans ce domaine
oui on peut dire que c'est un déni
démocratique et rappelez-vous personne
ne le dit
comment est née la convention citoyenne
elle est née après ce qu'on a appelé la
crise des du gilet jaune où des dizaines
de milliers de personnes des centaines
de milliers de personnes
partout en france on revendique et de la
justice sociale et climatique mais
surtout de la justice sociale ensuite on
a eu le grand débat national où en fait
on c'était le grand blabla nationale on
nous a beaucoup amusé et on a vu
beaucoup emmanuel mathon à la télé et à
la sortie de sa emmanuel macron a dit
vous n'aurez pas la justice sociale on
n'augmentera pas les salaires vous
n'aurez pas le riz mais par contre on va
faire une convention citoyenne en
essence
citoyens tirés au sort pour répondre aux
défis de demain et à ces citoyens là on
leur a dit vous avez les quais vous
devez répondre à une ambition c'est la
neutralité carbone en 2050
c'est une des propositions et on les
donnera sans filtre je le redis au
parlement directement par les 40
d'hommes et puis on a commencé à avoir
des dockers a notamment sur la question
de taxer les dividendes des actionnaires
et puis après on a enterré au fur et à
mesure un moratoire sur la scène g
et puis on a réduit de façon drastique
l'urgence par exemple celle de la
rénovation thermique des logements est
une véritable question parce qu'il faut
le redire le changement climatique
frappe de plein fouet d'abord les
catégories les plus populaires
c'est celle qui habite dans les passeurs
permis c'est celle qui aujourd'hui se
nourrit à la malbouffe
bref c'est les premiers concernés est en
réalité ce projet de loi a mis des
choses plutôt dans le dans le temps que
l'on salue on va rénover l'ensemble des
passoires thermiques à l'horizon 2030
voire 2035
alors que l'urgence elle est aujourd'hui
oui ça demande de mobiliser beaucoup de
milliards d'euros pour répondre dans
l'ensemble de ses urgences mais on a su
mobiliser beaucoup d'argent pour sauver
les entreprises n'est pas les emplois
on devrait pouvoir en mobiliser autant
peut-être même davantage pour sauver
louvier le climat même ma dernière
question justement les marches pour le
climat que l'on a vu par exemple hier
dans toute la france est-ce que selon
vous où elles peuvent s'affirmer comme
un un vrai mouvement social mais c'est
déjà mouvement social
je vous le redis j'étais présent hier
avec des élus et camarades communistes
j'ai vu aussi des militants écologistes
avaient aussi des militants insoumis
socialiste et de l'ensemble de la gauche
et surtout j'ai vu beaucoup des dizaines
de milliers de jeunes qui avaient des
pancartes comme on voit défiler avec des
slogans extrêmement politique nous
voulons changer le système
nous voulons mettre fin à la loi du
profit et donc oui c'est ce mouvement
social et citoyen qui peut faire bouger
les villes et qui peut contraindre
l'exécutif à revoir sa copie évidemment
ils pourront compter sur les différentes
oppositions quand le texte viendra
oc dans le book communistes républicains
citoyens écologistes sera extrêmement
mobilisés pour reprendre un certain
nombre de propositions qui ont été
évincés de la convention citoyenne mais
aussi en apporter d'autres parce que
nous avons aussi dans ce champ social et
dans ce sens écologique beaucoup de
choses à dire que nous portons depuis
longtemps notamment je pense à la
question du fret ferroviaire
je pense notamment à la question de
taxer les dividendes je pense notamment
à la question des rôles à rénovation
thermique des logements et sur tout un
tas de questions pour une agriculture
paysanne pour mettre fin au traité de
libre échange et notamment le ceta que
le gouvernement refuse toujours d'être à
l'ordre du jour du sénat
et donc nous serons extrêmement
mobilisés mais nous avons besoin de ce
mouvement social d'ampleur pour contrer
de l'exécutif à revoir sa copie merci
fabien gay d'avoir été avec mon
sénateurs pcf de 500 mille mercis